[Musik]
[Applaus]
was wäre nordkorea ohne seine tyrannisch
extravaganten diktatoren atombombentests
und beleidigungs duelle mit dem
us-präsidenten ja in der hochfrequenten
und hysterie getriebenen internationalen
aufmerksamkeitsökonomie würde es wohl
gnadenlos ablösen keiner würde diesen
abend land auch nur eine sekunde seiner
kostbaren fernsehen oder internet seite
widmen und auch sonst also außerhalb der
news wäre nordkorea nur ein sehr kleines
lichtlein es verfügt über keinerlei
konkurrenzfähige industrie oder
relevanten handel und die kaufkraft der
25 millionen einwohner ist etwa mit der
von bielefeld vergleichbar und von
bielefeld weiß ja auch niemand irgendwas
oder kennst du jemanden der mal in
bielefeld war
doch im unterschied zu bielefeld gibt es
nordkorea wirklich und was auf ganz real
ist sind die dortigen krassen
menschenrechtsverletzungen und dank
dieser und seines schon weit
fortgeschrittenen atomprogramms genießt
nordkorea auf vielen internationalen
foren und gipfeltreffen allerhöchste
aufmerksamkeit
aber die bielefelder macht das jetzt
bitte nicht nach nur damit ihr auch mal
so berühmt werden wie kim jong un denn
dieser hatte 2009 10 nicht gerade ein
gutes jahr und 2020 scheint nicht viel
besser zu werden
[Musik]
warum nun in nordkorea herrscht eine
nahrungsmittelkrise die ernteerträge
sind auf ein fünf jahres tief gefallen
schätzungen zufolge sind fast 40 der
nordkoreaner von nahrungsmittelknappheit
betroffen
der grund dafür die internationale
sanktionen dürren überschwemmungen und
allerlei sonstige fahrten zu welchen
sich welt und weltall gegen kim jong-un
verschworen haben mittlerweile sind in
nordkorea zehn millionen menschen auf
internationale humanitäre hilfe
angewiesen da kämen sie nicht einmal
mehr mit der mindest kalorienzahl
versorgen kann
südkorea hat 50.000 rund 30 angeboten um
den hunger zu mindern aber reist vom
kapitalistischen erzfeind annehmen
nordkorea geht es doch eigentlich
blendend seht her die nordkoreanische
wirtschaft ist trotz aller sabotageakte
der klassenfeinde seit jahren im
aufschwung moment mal echt nordkorea hat
wirtschaftswachstum oder ist das nur
eine weitere von kims propagandalügen
nein auf eine etwas merkwürdige
informelle und chaotische weise wie
weitgehend vom schwarzmarkt angetrieben
wird ist nordkoreas wirtschaft in den
letzten jahren tatsächlich gewachsen
wir sprechen hier über ein
unregelmäßiges wirtschaftswachstum aber
schätzungen zufolge betrug ist in
einigen jahren durchschnittlich sogar
fünf prozent aber freut sich nicht zu
früh denn der ausgangspunkt dieser
wachstumsraten war extremer armut und
all dieses wachstum kommt im grunde
genommen nur bestimmten städtischen
ballungsräumen zu gute 40 prozent der
nordkoreaner die in ländlichen gebieten
leben haben nicht einmal eine stabile
versorgung mit energie sei es strom oder
sonstige energieträger zum heizen die
menschen dort sind im grunde darauf
angewiesen im winter die wenigen
verbleibenden bäume in der sowieso
radikal abgeholzten landschaft sofort
feuer
[Musik]
ja und auf der anderen seite haben wir
das bild welches das regime zu erzeugen
versucht das neue prämien und die
glitzernden megaprojekte nicht nur in
der hauptstadt diesen projekten steht
die internationale staatengemeinschaft
natürlich sehr kritisch gegenüber sind
sie ausdruck des größenwahns von
klinikum und der jungen diktator der in
schweizer privatschule aufwachsen durfte
und sogar im psn ist oder eher ein
zeichen dafür dass das regime sich zum
besseren ändern will bei der antwort auf
diese frage bleibt es spannend aber seht
am besten selbst wenn in diesem video
wollen wir euch die wichtigsten
großprojekte nordkoreas vorstellen und
ich denke er wäre das ziemlich
überrascht sein
[Musik]
wären ja statistischen grau zum
kunterbunten größenwahn
wenn du an vielen yandex erinnerst du
dich vielleicht an dieses gigantische
pyramidenförmige hotel dessen
fertigstellung ein vermögen gekostet hat
eigentlich ist es wohl eher eine hülle
die seit mehr als 15 jahren keinen
einzigen arbeiter mal gesehen hat
zwischen 1992 und 2008 war der bau
völlig zum erliegen gekommen einfach
weil die nordkoreanische regierung nicht
über die mittel verfügte ihn fertig zu
stellen dies war die folge des
zusammenbruchs der sowjetunion und der
anschließenden hungersnot die mehr als
zwei von 22 millionen und koreaner das
leben kostet
ein zehntel der bevölkerung verhungerte
in den jahren 1994 bis 1998 bei diesen
komischen hotel handelt es sich um ein
gebäude das als eines der größten
symbole des regimes bezeichnet wird sein
bau wurde von kim il sung dem großvater
der kinder dass die in auftrag gegeben
während der gesamten ära kim jong-il es
blieb ist unvollendet und ging um und
ließ es schließlich mit glas und einem
riesigen led screen verkleidet was drin
ist weiß niemand genau
nach einem richtigen hotel sieht es
jedenfalls nicht aus und seit seiner
fertigstellung im jahr 2016 hat ist auch
kein einziger gast mehr betreten mit
anderen worten wir haben es hier mit
einer luxus attrappe aller erster güte
zu tun und glaubt ihr es nicht dass so
eine saubere attrappe in kirchheim
keinen sinn ergibt ganz im gegenteil sie
passt ausgezeichnet in games konzept
wie ihr versteht das jetzt nicht dann
wird euch mal folgendes in kenia gibt es
die mir ihre straße der wissenschaftler
mehrere bedeutet auf koreanisch zukunft
es ist eine straße voller wolkenkratzer
geschäfte und restaurants die
koreanische und internationale speisen
anbieten
das alles wurde als belohnung für
wissenschaftler die sich an games
atomprogramm verdient gemacht haben und
für regime-treue universitätsprofessoren
gebaut es handelt sich um eine
klassische gated community damit die
niederen klassen das luxusleben der
feinen herrschaften nicht stören
astreiner schulbuch sozialismus eben
aber das ist noch nicht alles
noch stehen schillernder ist die
ringstraße auch die an fetten genannt
glücklich zum 105 geburtstag von canon
dem zug wurden dort im april 2017 fast
20 glitzernden hochhäuser mit bis zu 70
stockwerken ein gewalt ihrer fassaden
sind blau und türkis gestrichen und so
geschickt mit kacheln verziert damit sie
wie die glasfassaden moderne
wolkenkratzer in südkorea und china aus
mit diesen projekten hat kind gleich
zwei ziel erreicht nach denen hat er den
nordkoreanischen führung style
klargemacht dass er ob seines noch
jungen alters derjenige sein würde der
das land modernisieren entwickeln und
umgestalten würde ganz gleich welche
steine ihm vom ausland in den weg gelegt
würden und nach außen will er damit
einen scheinbaren sinneswandel zum
modernen suggerieren gleichzeitig
selbstbewusst klar machen unseren
sozialismus in seinem lauf halten weder
trump noch irgendwelche sanktionen auf
und genau diese botschaft hält kim an
der macht und im hinblick auf seinen
machterhalt sind die ressourcen
nordkoreas in solchen luxus projekten
für privilegierte eben besser angelegt
als in der nahrungsversorgung der
breiten bevölkerung deswegen ist es klar
dass führen ja noch mehr luxus bekommt
cam hat schon ein neues mega projekt
vorgestellt das die nachbarschaft des
geister hotels völlig verändern soll
casey tivi enthüllt groß angelegte pläne
für den bezirk um das ikonische
regierung hotel garni muss aber moment
mal wenn du erst dachte ist das kämmen
die ausgefallensten post projekte nur in
der hauptstadt bauen lässt ist so
gewaltig falls du nicht sitzt setz dich
mal lieber hin
wir gehen jetzt mal nach sanieren auf
die halbinsel calma in die stadt bonn st
ok ich weiß das ganz genau was ihr durch
den kopf geht mein geschmack von diesen
ordnung hat doch keine sau jemals gehört
nun klar
bis jetzt denn bisher waren sie
vollkommen irrelevant aber kim der in
der schweiz zur schule gehen bekam wohl
etwas fernweh und er wollte sein eigenes
skigebiet in europäischem spiel haben
und auch ein eigenes ferienparadies für
den sommerurlaub nur gesagt getan
das offizielle ziel nordkorea zur
tourismushochburg zu machen
nun im jahr 2018 besuchte dort korea
eine rekordzahl von touristen 1,2
millionen 50 prozent wachstum gegenüber
dem feuer wo kann diese her fast alle
aus china natürlich und alle in
ständiger begleitung von
nordkoreanischen fremdenführern die jede
ihrer bewegungen strengstens überwachen
ein toller roboter sein und käme selbst
wirklich alles in bewegung um trotz
internationaler sanktionen alle devisen
zu kommen zwei neue stätte für winter
und sommer
um dort co realen so etwas wie das
thailand nord ost asiens zu verwandeln
gibt gummierung und viel geld aus um
faire in komplexe zu errichten
eigentlich zu viel geld wenn man die
miese lage des landes tränen betracht
die beiden größten beispiele sind
familien und cameleon ist eine stadt am
fuße des berges paektu der nach
koreanische tradition als der
gründungsort der nation gilt und
nordkoreanische propaganda cartoons
wollen uns auch davon überzeugen dass
kinder ihren will an diesem ort geboren
wurde
die hand die vöglein sangen und eine
bunte regenbogen über den horizont passt
tatsache ist dass diese region heute
besser dafür bekannt ist einer der
schönsten naturräume des landes zu sein
und fantastische bedingungen für den
wintersport bietet und deswegen
beschloss kim jong-un genau dort seine
miniatur schweiz zu bauen
deshalb ordnete an einfach die ganze
stadt abzureißen um eine ganz neue stadt
mit einem großen hotel geschäften
unglücken und häusern mit farbigen der
schätze bauen sie sollte 4000 familien
380 öffentliche und gewerbliche objekte
und natürlich einige ski-pisten
beherbergen all dies wurde in anderthalb
jahren umgesetzt das blatt was nun nennt
er aber ein wenig hinter den vorhang
schauen und ist diese geschichte
natürlich nicht ganz so beeindruckend um
den bau termingerecht zu schließen setzt
das regime auf quasi sklavenarbeit und
die armee riesige arbeiter herre wurden
aus den zwangsarbeitslager mobilisiert
und der strom aus den umliegenden
städten umgeleitet so dass diese über
lange zeit gar keinen strom mehr hatten
und all dies irgendwie geplante schieße
so 2020 fertig zu werden
mit dem krone locker und in china hat
damals noch niemand gerechnet und wenn
es eine sache gibt die kinder unbedingt
braucht dann sind es die riesen dollar
euro yen yuan auf jeden fall wurde
sammler vom regime als die
sozialistische utopie angepriesen es
sollte der welt zeigen dass das regime
ein winterparadies erschaffen kann
geschäftsführerin ist renommierten
preetz architekturpreises steht das
jedoch ein bisschen anders
es ist ein einfaches skigebiet es
berücksichtigt keinerlei moderne
stadtplanung es legt wenig wert auf
wohnqualität und kluge flächennutzung
und es schafft keine räume in denen die
menschen ein erfülltes leben führen
können massa vorne geschäftsführerin des
kreises aber ungeachtet dieser debatten
über stadtplanung und der tatsache dass
alles auf ein ökonomisches desaster
hinausläuft ist derzeit einer der
schönsten orte miesesten land der welt
[Musik]
und worauf er ist alle unglaublich
gespannt ist ob ihm dies noch mal
gelingen kann nämlich in der stadt
wonsan auf kalmar dort haben wir nämlich
das exakte gegenstück zum
schneebedeckten sanieren
ein echtes sommerparadies eine fünf
kilometer lange strandpromenade an der
sich ein ferien komplex an den anderen
reiht aller derzeit noch im bau
begriffen dazu ein vollkommen neu
gestalteter flughafen mit einem blitz
blank funkelnden terminal ohne fluggäste
demir ohne will daraus dass
nordkoreanische miami den
kommunistischen ballermann oder
erdbeertorte machen die kosten machen
ist für das verarmte nordkorea zum
vielleicht teuersten und kims loses ein
projekt des letzten jahrzehnts die rede
ist von zwölf hotels zwei einkaufstüten
26 geschäftsgebäuden kinos einem
ausstellungs palast einem spiel
hallengebäude einem überdachten
wasserpark eine eislaufbahn einem
restaurant komplex und mehr als 48
willen und 200 luxus chalets überall
dort sollen den touristen die dollars
aus der tasche gelockt werden und alice
spielt sich in einem land ab dass der
welt verschlossen ist und in dem ein
großer teil der bevölkerung in extremer
armut der massenhaften hunger versinkt
für die allermeisten nordkoreaner werden
wollen von monstern immer unerreichbar
sein
aber die eliten des landes hohe beamte
und vielleicht auch einige touristen
werden sie umso mehr genießen können ach
ja das ist dann wohl der sozialistische
traum so und julian simon und wasser
sind noch lange nicht dass kindle dieser
wirklich traurigen fan stand da ist zb
der bau dieses sonnen förmigen hotels
ins kino an der grenze zu china
es soll geschäftsleute beherbergen
sobald die sonderwirtschaftszone sinuiju
zwischen nordkorea und china eröffnet
wird im moment ist diese zone durch
internationale sanktionen lahmgelegt
[Musik]
die idee ist alle regionen entlang des
flussufers des dialogs zu reformieren
nicht nur die wachsende wirtschaftliche
aktivität zu nutzen die sich diesem
gebiet dank des handels mit china und
des schwarzmarktes an dem die regierung
selbst beteiligt ist zusammengebraut
sondern auch um den chinesischen
nachbarn auf der anderen seite der
grenze wo die wohlhabende chinesische
stadt dandong liegt eine bild
wirtschaftliche entwicklung und
wachsenden wohlstands zu zeigen und
dadurch mit den wichtigsten
megaprojekten nordkoreas hat bist gibt
es etwas das sie jetzt aber wirklich
klar stellen müssen all diese projekte
wirken wie beispiel für echten
wirtschaftlichen fortschritts würden
aber die realität sieht ganz anders aus
in den meisten fällen ist das schicksal
solcher projekte nämlich gähnende leere
einfach weil keine kunden kommen die
bereit sind für irgendetwas zu bezahlen
das ergebnis sind deine geisterstädte
und wenn kim sein land nicht radikal
öffnet werden hunderte von millionen
dollar und hunderte millionen zwangs
arbeitsstunden verpuffen und dieser
hätte man ja schließlich für viele
notwendige dinge verwenden können wie
zum beispiel die verbesserung der
schlechten infrastruktur im ganzen land
damit du dir ein bild machen kannst von
den mehr als 25.500 kilometern straßen
in nordkorea sind nur 800 kilometer
asphaltierte sind noch nicht mal drei
prozent all diese ressourcen könnten
auch für dämme bewässerungs pipelines
und herausgegeben werden um
überschwemmungen bei starken regenfällen
zu vermeiden und auch um wasserreserven
zu sammeln die den wiederkehrenden
dürren uns damit der
nahrungsmittelknappheit ein ende
bereiten würden oder sie könnten auch
dafür verwendet werden die
stromversorgung abzusichern da der
größte teil des landes nachts in
dunkelheit gehüllt ist aber natürlich
ist mein skigebiete und eine ferienstadt
viel schicker wie auch immer jetzt ist
deine meinung gefragt was denkst du
glaubst du dass das land in allgemeinen
von diesen tourismusprojekten
profitieren kann wie können sie diese
hotels füllen während nordkorea ein so
isoliertes land der unterdrückung bleibt
ein land an dem sich ein tourist nicht
einmal ohne fremdenführer bewegen
schreibt uns darüber
kommentarbereich als ihr denkt dass euch
dieses video etwas gebracht hat geht
wird auch in like und bis zum nächsten
mal
[Musik]